bonjour lui commande vous êtes là vous
allez remettre un petit peu d'ordre dans
cette émission choqué quoi je pensais
pas que c'était sait faire aussi vite
alors et médailles je peux vous dire
c'est jamais la dernière et j'avais la
première enfin c'est surtout la première
alors question 4 car c'est en attendait
ça aussi avec impatience et ben voilà
alors une question tout de suite bien
sûr ils sont 5 et 3 parce qu'il y en a
il ça sent mauvais la guitare on dit que
le succès change beaucoup les gens dont
je voulais savoir si c'était le cas pour
cyril hanouna ou si au contraire il
avait réussi à rester aussi con qu'avant
qu'est-ce que je crois aujourd'hui de
rémission c'est une très bonne question
chère anita car oui le succès peut
changer des ans mais pas cyril non lui
c'est un homme équilibré qui se donnent
à fond pour cette émission
quitte à mettre en danger sa santé un
nouveau chroniqueur qui va rejoindre
l'équipe de tout ça on poste 2
j'ai eu un problème en pension à partir
de plus tôt à mon poste alors si tu fait
applaudir sont des malins alors c'est
vrai que cette attelle a beaucoup
intrigué les téléspectateurs à l'époque
que c'est est il réellement passé vous
vous en souvenez oui j'avais danser et
mon talon était venu cogner l'on doit
car si c'était vraiment fait mal et pas
en dansant comme il le prétend car j'ai
les images c'est en quoi en fait ah bah
je préviens c'est bizarre je pense qu'il
ya que chez nous qu'on peut avoir ce
genre d'accident
avant la prise d'antenne le mec sound et
couple est tout seul tout va bien mais
le pire c'est quand on voit les extraits
dans sa continuité alors l'extrait la
continuité je voulais pas la montrer et
hélas mon ami bertrand là mon absence il
hier pour me traiter de traître donc
comme on est dans les coups bas
expliquez moi juste la cohérence des 18
secondes qui vont suivre l'accident 130
soldats en poste bouffioux
c'est l'été
alors
on ceux qui voudraient faire la télé je
résume le conducteur de l'émission doit
casser je te bouffe le cul réalisateur
qui donne des ordres dans l'oreillette
on est en retard on saute le beauf et qu
on va direct humanité vous supplie le
havre souffre en push surprend pas bien
sûr en péril ce n'est pas un camion de
berlu c'est aussi un créateur de génie
vous le savez le seul cave de créer une
chanson et un jeu pendant les coming
next parce que les communes ex vous êtes
très créatif 1 alors je vous ai mixer
les deux pour vous apprécié de 9,2 et
surtout sa fierté
brooke et qui dit petit bourg a goûté tu
mourras gauche qui mourra debout tout va
te faire cueillir le q7
je voudrais également remercier ses
divisions
allez aimer c'est drôle on fait avec et
enfin bâtir sur le cul bon ce à quoi ça
qu'est bon ragoût de tous kéké mollahs
goût de tous va faire cueillir le tue
sabban pas de faire cuire le tu sais moi
tu me carter le clip où là tout son jeu
passe quelque chose fonctionne
aujourd'hui j'adore pas de faire cuire
le tout c'est moi
génie créatif c'est pas avoir proposé
par mois le premier numéro du va te
faire cuire le cul sans doute en
permission d vite présenté par laurence
ferrari mais il est très créatif il
laisse rien perdre ses séries est un
leader qui essaient toujours de nous
mettre en valeur notamment en nous
présentant regardez là il va donner le
nouveau surnom de bertrand chamerois
pour le plus grand plaisir de jean
michel maire pour rester avec nous via
leurs appareils de plein de choses avec
vous mais juste avant il ya le playback
de l'équipe bien sûr
bertrand cherche à me roy qui tabac
m
aulas
vanité de cet homme
oui un monde s'écroule pour jean-michel
mai mais tel un chat il va retomber sur
ses pattes comme bertrand a pris la
place du playboy
jean-michel d'essayer de prendre la
place du jeune attention une compilation
de moment triste sort de la nuit les
gros cigares iedom
ja
et vous
sami yen sont un autre en 1913
ouais c'est pas vous les kids
la mission vous allez chanter dans un
club de strip tease
vous avez commencé et 3 3
une grosse guerrier tournoi
cash talent mais si la radio ça le rend
fou il faut qu'il arrête on enlevait
faut lui dire la vérité à l'arrêter mais
je vous rassure si le nouveau jean
michel est jeune il reste toujours aussi
méchant par exemple il ya deux semaines
des choses très rare eh ben je crois que
ça avait une seule fois dans l'émission
il y avait plus de chroniqueuse que deux
chroniqueurs pour la plus grande joie de
valérie bénaïm j'ai envie d'être
oh la la voilà je suis une fille et
brême sais que tu sais comment sont les
filles elles sont méchantes
très méchante
donc je pourrais diffuser les
commentaires sur mokhtar pendant les
danses de syrie mais maintenant parce
que mokhtar est la moins d'humour que
moi donc ça serait dangereux pour toi
europe ici
on va s'en occuper mokhtar vous
inquiétez pas alors je me suis toujours
une fille non non non parce que c'est
pas fini
motard jean michel a juste un petit
message pour toi à français diront
mokhtar d une lavette raclure de bidet
compute aura des rires villa
parce que je sais que trois heures et il
a dit sombre merde c'est alors qu'est ce
qu'on fait on continue on va être sur
cette page alors elle va me rue
aujourd'hui qu'il faut que vous nous
vous voulez nous parler d'autre chose
alors j'ai encore plein de choses assez
il faut passer on passe un magnéto et
après voilà dernier parce que vous aurez
noté au passage que cyril a placé un
discret touche à ton cul tu auras des
verrues oui c'est bien mais le problème
c'est que comme d'habitude après jean
michel a voulu avoir le dernier mot non
il a cherché
leurs liens sont comme air tout s'attend
plutôt à des verrues
auzits
pas facile quand on est en bas comme
d'habitude et aux 15 secondes et n'était
pas loin du de sessad de l'accident
cérébral a déclaré je partirai classique
c'est une vraie question enquêteurs j'ai
souvent montré isabelle se prendre un
vent avec cirino avec d autres
chroniqueurs sais c'est pas toujours
valorisant pour elle mais ce qui est
pire finalement c'est quand tu te prends
un double vent avec un enfant de 10 ans
oui il ya quelques semaines le petit
baptiste était sur notre plateau et dans
son regard vous allez voir on peut lire
mais qu'est ce qu'elle veut la dame
bon
globalement pour leurs droits de vote y
compris par s'attirer jean-michel ont
été très surpris par une infirmation de
cyril hanouna nous aimait bien shediac
ont dit ah ouais il est sexy c'est bien
c'est bien le côté un peu intello ça de
lui c'est ainsi
pourquoi laisser dire ça vous avez un
look d'intello j'ai un look d'intervenir
bah si mais après bon après c'est oui
mais vous aimez vous c'est ça la vérité
ouais enfin c'est un ami julien on va
pas revenir là dessus c'est bon c'est
pas ça le problème
ils sont surveillés qu'on puisse dire
que je viens est un intellectuel c'est
normal car le seul hôtel que l'équipe
sait qui c'est jean michel bats
évidemment c'est sûr en attendant on
passe au pire des jt étrangers c'est le
journal des gitans
un journal d giteau bien sûr je vous ai
gardé le vent de la semaine voire du
mois a alors vous savez cyril est un
homme généreux
donc il ne nous cache rien parfois c'est
dommage car tout le monde n'est pas prêt
à entendre ces délicieuses confidences
comme ici muriel notre maquilleuse à
on
mais papa tu sais que je fais caca trois
quatre fois par an
c'est beaucoup c'est un signe de bonne
santé ça va voir ce qui m'a dit pas
parce que je me repose beaucoup gâché
beaucoup cac à mon avis ça fait du bien
en foot on la pousse
ce cachet voulut pas des magnifiques
confidences elle apprécie leur
dépression je parlais tout à l'heure je
parlais à une autre question a bien sûr
va on y va
nouvelle question bonjour je m'appelle
annie des gains chroniqueur fine
l'interview ne peut pas s'empêcher de
lécher le derrière d'assurer la normale
donc je voulais juste savoir qui est
encore bonne haleine dans votre équipe
la question c'est une excellente
question que vous posez la chaire dick
même si nous nous en parlons peu c'est
vrai que ces traits essentiels les gènes
du quarantenaire d'un milieu audiovisuel
car nos chroniqueurs nous aimons cyril
plus que de raison et pas uniquement
parce qu'il peut en un claquement de
doigts des maîtres disait notre badge
d'entrée à des beats non nous l'aimons
car c'est un homme courageux qui s'y
sont engagés sur des sujets sensibles
quitte à déranger les bien pensants là
il s'est exprimé sur l'heure d'été à
nîmes on se lève le matin il fait nuit
on rentre le soir ip nuit ça veut dire
qu'on a l'impression d'être toujours
dans un tunnel
ah voilà et les tunnels j'ai envie de
dire stop bafta arrivederci voilà je
vous le dis
et on en fait un peu trop mais
franchement ça se voit pas alors pour
que vous vous en rendiez vraiment
content
voici un nouveau numéro du pôle manège
malgré tous ses efforts
elle recule d'une place et fait donc
sentir peut dériver naim du classement
enora malagré c'est un producteur qui
croient en des nouveaux talents et qui
nous aide aussi à progresser
tesson cyril c'est le service alors
qu'il croit en moi qui me lâche pas je
pourrais en pleurer quoi
il
il se fait frapper pendant les pauses
publicitaires mais il est quand même
content d'être là il méritait donc bien
sa quatrième place bertrand chan aura et
avec série l'on sait jamais ce qui peut
se passer
et puis il ya une ambiance super
concerne l'équipe
c'est un ensemble de choses qui me fait
rester numéro 1 qui perd deux places
alors qu'il se pensait indéboulonnable
jean luc lemoine
puis je pense que pour tous les
chroniqueurs vous savez ce que c'est
c'est
c'est l'étoile york
celui conçu est exactement c'est pas
anodin de dire l'étoile du berger parce
que les bergers venus et c'est aussi la
déesse de la beauté
chez lui le léchage est tellement
constant que sa langue est maintenant
toute lisse jean michel bayle moi c'est
vous chef c'est plus lui même nommé
quatre ans en quatre ans j'ai lâchement
dans des délais bien la musique
française
le baril ça dépend dès qu'une personne
ne s'en méfier il fait une entrée
fracassante en arrivant directement la
première place julien courbet il a une
sorte de génie du divertissement
sur plus de ça moi je le vois faire je
prends une claque
je vais vous dire un truc et je le pense
vraiment j'ai plus appris
les temps au tour de la table en le
regardant en quelques mois un an que
pendant des années
enfin mettez vous à la place des
dirigeants des huit ils assurent
peut-être 60% du chiffre d'affaires à
lui tout seul il a donné la masse cette
station
il n'y a pas de concurrence avec cyril
vraiment l'ascendant qu'il peut pas y
avoir encore c'est le paris saint
germain et nous on est derrière et
je me retirais avec ça voilà mais lui
même si non il va faire plus que ça la
déesse de la beauté je pouvais pas faire
plus ça c'est bon c'est quand vous
voulez rama nand à mie question on est
bien on dirait une dernière question et
je m'en vais bonjour je m'appelle anita
je voulais savoir si bertrand chamerois
aimait les femmes plus âgées que lui car
j'en ferais bien mon casse croûte de ce
petit plus haut
jusqu'à jean luc et jean luc montreuil
ce soit avec nous bien sûr dans l'offre
lahoud